Shantanu: We tell teachers that you
shouldn't be the sage on the stage
but you should actually
be the guide on the side.
But they really don't have the tools
that are necessary to really
make that possible today.
One of the big differences
with Khan Academy
is that we're not trying to just replicate
the existing systems using technology
to augment the way existing
instruction is done.
We're fundamentally thinking
about reinventing instruction.
Sal: We've gotten letters
from teachers who said,
"Hey, you've already given the lecture
on L'Hopitals rule or the unit circle."
Instead of me giving the
basic lecture on that
and then assigning
homework, we flip the model.
I'm assigning the lecture
for them to watch at home
and then they can watch what I assign.
But then if they have some
questions they can re-mediate
and watch stuff that was
taught in previous sections.
Or if they're bored they can move
ahead and go as advance as they want.
Then when they go into the classroom
they can actually do problems,
they should do their
homework in the classroom.
We have this teacher dash board right now
where it shows all of the
students and all of the concepts.
Within a glance a teacher
can see whose mastered what,
who's struggling with what,
where each student is in their
development and learning.
They can see in real time where
all the students are in aggregate.
The coach will be able to see who's stuck.
They can click on any one of the concepts
and see exactly what the
students have been up to.
By problem, they can see how
long they spent on each problem.
Did they get it right or wrong?
Did they watch the video before
or after working on that problem.
If they saw that they got a problem wrong
they can actually click on that part
and see the exact problem
that they got wrong,
so they can really diagnose and
do very focused interventions
to kind of make sure that all
of the students are progressing.
In every other industry, if you want to
diagnose why something is not working,
you try to get as much
data on it as possible,
so that you can really say, "Okay,"
"I need to just tighten
that part right over there."
What we're trying to do is give
teachers that level of data.
Shantanu: We can just try to
impact individuals directly
without having to change the
entire educational system.
Sal: To roll out it's actually super
simple, it's all web based, it's all free,
so literally if a school has internet
connectivity and has computers,
any type of computer, they're ready
to start 1 + 1 and get to Calculus.